(light music)
- [Narrator] Today,
about 4.2 billion people
have access to a world of information
never before seen.
Such an extraordinary
level of connectedness
has revolutionized everything.
From science and technology,
to commerce and romance,
and virtually every aspect of out lives.
(upbeat music)
Of all the technological
innovations in history,
few have made as strong of
an impact as the internet.
Comprised by a global
network of computers,
the internet allows for the transmission
of information and connectivity
at an unprecedented speed and scale.
Some of the first computer networks
began in the 1950s and 60s,
but unlike today's global network,
these early networks were centralized
within certain businesses and agencies.
It wasn't until 1969 when
centralized computer networks
became connected.
Funded by the US Department of Defense,
and developed by universities,
this host-to-host network
connection, called ARPANET,
a direct ancestor of the internet,
was the first of its kind.
The network grew, and by the 1980s,
incorporate networks at
research institutions
and other US Federal agencies,
such as the National
Science Foundation, or NSF.
The NSF connected these disparate networks
into one large one.
NSFNET, which shifted over from being
a federally run network
to a commercial enterprise
for internet service providers.
- Telecommunications is going to become
much much more important.
Your computer is going to become
your window into the world, really,
in some degree.
(modem connection noises)
- [Narrator] By the late 1990s,
this shift, along with the
rise of personal computers,
the world wide web, and web browsers,
allowed the general public
to access the internet
for the very first time.
Today, computers, smart
phones, televisions,
video game consoles, and other devices,
all tap into the network,
and transmit and receive
data almost instantly.
For example, by clicking
send in messaging apps,
text, audio, and video are converted
into pieces of electronic
data called packets.
These packets are then
tagged with a port number
and IP address.
Much like the mailing
address on an envelope,
the port number and IP
address direct the packets
to a given destination on the internet.
From there, the packets may travel
over Wifi, cellular data, or
an ethernet or phone line.
Through a series of routers,
modems, and servers,
then through fiber optic
cables or satellites,
and through a similar process in reverse
to reach the packets destination.
Once the packets arrive,
their data is reassembled into the text,
audio, or video that was originally sent.
(machine buzzing)
(light music)
Since the days of the
earliest computer networks,
the internet has undergone
a tremendous transformation,
while also transforming
the world that created it.
From a closed off network,
to one that covers the globe,
the internet has provided
access to information
to every continent,
connecting people and
ideas like never before.